for folks who don't know who you are if
you don't mind taking a moment and
sharing your story with them that'd be
great sure well thank you first of all
let me say my dad spent three years in a
refugee camp after world war ii waiting
for the united states congress that one
day his youngest son that'd be me passed
a law called the displaced persons act
which allowed my father millions of
others like him with these long and hard
to pronounce last names a chance to come
to america so my late father had
something come with you because you
spent a couple of years right
in germany um look in so many ways in
fact it was my life was the american
dream my mother and father were working
people my mom was american born
if she'd have come from the old country
like my dad i think my first name would
have been as hard to pronounce as my
last name i had never been the governor
of illinois but then again i had never
been inmate number four zero eight nine
two four two four
but my life's been
the american dream because of the
success that i was fortunate to have
because so many people helped me then it
was the kafka nightmare that came after
it when i was sent to prison was
compelled to shelter in place for eight
years for politics not for crimes from
what the wall street journal called
practicing politics
but you know the values that made you so
successful
patrick are the values my mother and
father instilled in me that you're
fortunate lucky to live in a great
country like this a land of opportunity
it's supposed to be a land of freedom
it's a fragile gift that we have that we
shouldn't take for granted i've learned
some hard lessons about that but it's a
place where if you dream you can reach
those dreams if you're prepared to work
hard to make those dreams real i've been
working since i was nine years old
shining shoes
and um
i'm still working and when i was in
prison it's funny because i was earning
about five dollars and 25 cents a month
in prison i earned more money as a
nine-year-old shining shoes in chicago
then i made as a former governor in my
early 60s and a lawyer and a lawyer and
and all the rest so you know i've been
up i've been down but there's an old
irish proverb that says even god can't
make two mountains without a valley in
between so i'm climbing back up and it's
fun as you know the journey is even more
fun than the destination so what's next
for you what do you mean yeah i watch
your i watch the documentary and here's
one of the things i notice about you
it didn't matter when it was
whether it's you're walking out and
you're about to go to jail you're
shaking hands hey you're hugging this
lady and your wife's to your left and
you're hugging you're kissing on the
cheek and you're hugging this other lady
you're always in in campaign mode have
you always been this guy that's shaking
hands building relationships have you
always been that guy
you know what i don't know you know i
guess so i don't know maybe yes maybe no
i when i was shining shoes i know when i
was a kid in order to get the tips you
got to hustle right you got to get out
there and schmooze a little bit and try
to do a good job shine his shoes and try
to keep the black shoe polish off the
the white socks of the guy who's an
engineer who shouldn't be wearing white
socks or black shoes right
um they should fire that guy
or maybe he's a fan of jerry lewis i
think jerry lewis used to do something
like that he used to wear white socks
with black shoes right that's right
those old movies
um but
you know i i uh
i guess so you know i wasn't exactly
great in school i went to public school
in chicago i wasn't set the world on
fire schools were you in high school
like if we were in high school together
who was who was if i asked one of your
classmates that was in high school with
you 10th grade 11th grade who was rob
somebody who didn't do so good in
physics and got a d in algebra which was
a classic case of great inflation
um
you know i played on the high school
basketball team i bought gold and gloves
in chicago first time i ever got my name
in the newspaper chicago tribune was the
golden globes when i was 17 18 years old
i grew up a real city life in a big city
like chicago
but i was lucky to have great parents
that you know worked hard and sacrificed
so i can go to college and it was them
their hard work and sacrifice that gave
me a chance to
get up high in politics now as i said
looking back
it's a mixed blessing in view of what's
happened but i do believe and i had
2896 days to think when i was sheltering
in place in prison
and i do believe god has a plan for all
of us and i think as bad as that was
as is written in genesis what they meant
for evil god meant for good and i feel
like there's some service that i can
still provide as well as working hard to
build a better life for my daughters and
my wife so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]